So, let's go back to our usual road map.
So, today we are going to still focus on
closed-loop methods for optimal control,
particularly through the lens of dynamic
programming in a discrete-time
formulation.
But, we're going to extend the
formulation to the setting whereby we
have uncertainty
in our system. Particularly, we're going
to reason about disturbances that might
affect the forward propagation of the
dynamics for you for for the state.
The setting that we're going to discuss
is a very famous one and is referred to
as the Markov decision processes
setting.
So, specifically, remember the
problem formulation we've been
discussing for the past
two three lectures. So, now we're in
discrete time. So, the update equations
for the state are written as SK + 1 = F
of K
SK
UK.
So, this would have been the setting
until the previous lecture, but now
we're adding an additional element, WK.
WK is referred to as a disturbance.
It is something that uh
affects the forward propagation of our
dynamics and depending on the specific
application might have different uh
uh meanings. For example, if you are if
you want to control an aircraft, WK
could be environmental uncertainty, for
example, wind gusts.
If we're trying to control
the uh financial market,
uh like basically we want to decide how
to buy and sell the stocks. WK might
represent the underlying uncertainty
within the market, and so on and so
forth.
So, the idea is that you observe the
state XK.
You take a control UK.
And then, nature is going to pinpoint a
value of WK.
This order is somewhat arbitrary, but
you have to fix an order in order to
make this model actionable.
Now,
as it was the case of the deterministic
setting, we are still assuming that the
controls need to belong to some set
capital Q.
That is, our
set of controls is, in general,
constrained
within some
set capital U.
Now, the disturbance W are quantities
that are computed by nature,
in a way.
And so, they are modeled as uh
random variables.
And we do place a key assumption on the
distribution of such random variables W.
Specifically, we assume
that the random variables WK
are distributed according to some
general probability distribution.
It could be Gaussian, it could be
anything.
They can be conditional on the current
value of the state and the current
selection of the control.
So, you are in a state XK, you get to
see that state.
You pick a control U.
Based on that,
there is some realization of the
disturbance value.
Of course, in some setting, actually
this probability distribution
does not does not need to depend on X
and U. That's perfectly valid.
What is important though, is that this
probability distribution is not allowed
to depend on the previous values of the
state. So, it's not allowed to depend on
X K minus 1,
X K minus 2, and so on. So, it's not
allowed to depend on the history of the
process.
That's a fundamental assumption we're
making in our model. It's typically good
assumption,
meaning that the realization of your
disturbances and essentially uncertainty
in your environment only depends on the
current state and current selection of
the control. But, for example, if you're
driving, what the other pedestrian might
do next could be modeled as a
disturbance. And of course, what the
pedestrian is going to do next depend on
where we are with our car and what we
plan to do, turning right right or left.
So,
so it makes sense.
But, there are cases where actually you
would like to model
the dependency on the previous values of
the states. Well, that's not allowed in
this problem setting. So, it's a
restriction, but it's a mild
restriction. Again, why do we place
these restrictions in our settings is to
find a good compromise between
um generality of our problem formulation
and a problem formulation that allow us
to do some computation, basically
uh derive some uh
uh recipes to compute our control
policies in an actionable way.
I'll come back to this assumption later.
As it was the case of the deterministic
setting, we are interested in
closed-loop control, so we are
interested in finding controls that are
expressed as a
uh a closed-loop policy. So, a function
pi that maps uh any state in the world
into an optimal control action.
And finally, the last ingredient in our
problem formulation is the cost. So, the
cost is going to be expressed as the
summation of a terminal cost, as usual,
plus a stage-wise cost, as usual.
Now, the stage-wise cost could actually
depend on the disturbance.
We'll see some examples later.
And importantly, since you have uh a
dependency of the cost on the
disturbance, that cost itself is a
random variable.
So, you want to translate that random
variable in something deterministic that
you can uh minimize or maximize,
depending your setting, in order to uh
define a notion of optimality for your
policy.
To do that,
there are different ways to do it.
We, in this problem formulation, select
to
compute an expectation of the cost. The
expectation is with respect to the
realization of all the disturbance
variables.
Make sense?
So, main differences here
are that the um
state transition function depends on the
disturbance W.
W is a random quantity
with an arbitrary probability
distribution. It is constrained, though,
of being only conditional on the current
value of the state of control. It cannot
depend on previous values of the state.
And the cost
is allowed to depend on uh the
disturbance, but since we have such a
dependency, all this term is now a
stochastic quantity. So, to reduce it to
a deterministic quantity we can optimize
over, we take an expectation of it. And
then the the problem is to find a policy
pi that optimizes such a cost.
So, any questions here? So, this is uh
important we're all on the same page,
otherwise everything I'm going to
discuss next is not going to make much
sense. Yeah.
>> Just to clarify, you said that at each
stage the disturbance value
on the disturbance in the prior stage.
>> Unless
uh um
only indirectly through the state. So,
the state mediates your dependence on
the history. Of course, the evolution of
the state depends on the disturbances.
But, everything that
is related to the history of uh
the process,
previous states, previous controls,
previous uh disturbances, all of that
knowledge is mediated through the
realization of the current state.
Yeah.
>> Does the cost change depending on when
you sample the W K?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Like, for example, you are trying to
control an aircraft, depending on what
the actual realization of your wind
profile is, the cost of the trajectory
is going to change.
>> But, do you only factor in like
I guess three iterations?
>> No, the problem
is that you want to find a policy that
is optimal
with respect to all possible realization
of
those uncertainties.
And one way to collapse all those
realization of those uncertainties in a
number you can optimize over is to take
the expectation of your cost
with respect to all possible
realizations.
So, maybe sometimes you are unlucky,
sometimes you're lucky, so you want to
compute the policy that on average is
going to do good enough.
Yeah, so it's the expectation over all
realizations of the disturbances at time
0, 1, 2, all the way to N minus 1.
Other questions here?
So, this is the setting of Markov
decision processes.
Now,
there are variations, right? So, as we
will discuss later,
maybe you're not just interested in
expected value of your cost. Maybe
you're also interested in expectation
plus some notion of variability. So, you
don't you want to make sure that on
average you do good enough and there are
no cases whereby you could do terribly
poorly.
Or
another setting that we're not going to
cover in this class is rather than
modeling the disturbance as a stochastic
quantity
to model it in an adversarial fashion.
So, assuming that at every point in time
the disturbance that is realized is the
worst possible. This that leads to
minimax problems.
There is no stochasticity. Basically,
now becomes a game against nature uh
with some sort of game theoretical
interpretation whereby you try to
compute an action and nature tries to
compute the other action that is uh
maximally damaging. Anyway, we're not
going to solve to see those settings.
Markov. So, Markov mean
I did not come up with this formulation,
unfortunately. Otherwise, I would
receive the couple Nobel Prizes.
So, because of Remember that when we
compute the cost, the cost is additive.
It takes into account
the cost of the full state trajectory.
But the cost of the full state
trajectory depends on the realization of
all the disturbances.
That said,
the state evolution
only is only affected by the current
realization of the state. And as we will
see, dynamic programming will try to
break down this complex cost that
depends on all these nested realization
of the disturbance into expectation
uh with respect to each this one
disturbance at a time.
Does this address your question?
>> Um
>> Somewhat.
Yeah, that's it.
>> The wild obviously causes this problem
because it has a lot of possibilities.
>> Well, as I was telling your colleague,
keep in mind that once you move into the
new state SK + 1
SK + 2
is only going to be affected
directly by WK + 1.
But SK + 1 came from here, and SK + 1
was affected by
WK. So, you can see how SK + 2 has a
direct dependency on WK + 1 and indirect
dependency on WK.
So, actually each state does indeed
depend on all previous disturbance
realizations, but directly only on the
most current one.
At least in this formulation, that's how
we started the problem. Does it make
sense?
So, SK + 1 too doesn't it depend on WK?
Absolutely.
But that dependency, as I was
uh saying telling to your colleague
before, is mediated through the
realization of the state SK + 1.
All right. So, a few key points. So,
this is discrete-time model, obvious.
Is a Markovian model. Markovian model
means that uh we do not have an explicit
dependency on the history of the
process.
Everything is mediated through the
current value of the state.
Practically, what that means is that the
probability distribution for the
stochastic disturbance can only depend
on SK and UK. Cannot depend, for
example, on SK - 1.
The objective is to find a closed-loop
policy.
In a stochastic setting, this is
even more important since stochasticity
is bringing us left and right. So, you
really want to have a policy that maps
whatever you are in the state space into
a control
in a
optimal control action.
The cost is additive. Additive, that's
usual. That's same as in the
deterministic setting.
And we use a risk-neutral formulation.
What does it that mean? That in order to
compute the cost,
here we take an expectation.
We do not
model
additional considerations such as as I
was saying before, variability with
respect to the average. In some
settings, for example, even as a human
when you try to optimize your life,
you try to optimize for your
average income if you make a bet, but
also you try to protect yourself from
the worst case or from excessive
variability. So, this formulation is not
doing that. It's only modeling what is
going to happen on average.
There are more sophisticated formulation
referred to as a risk-sensitive. When
you add additional terms such as, for
example, a variance term and so on.
The problem with those formulations is
that they make a computation much more
complicated.
In their most, you know, naive uh
uh in the most naive approaches,
standard dynamic programming equations
no longer hold, the principle of
optimality no longer holds. So, you need
to do, you know, additional analysis in
order to come up with uh practical
algorithms. Actually, this is a topic
that I've done quite a bit of research
Uh uh in the past. Anyways,
for this class we're only going to focus
on the risk-neutral formulation.
The reason why the expectation is nice
is it intuitively
the expectation is itself a linear
function. So, it allows you to chop the
problem in multiple stages to be, you
know, very practical. But, we'll see
that in a second.
Now,
as I also mentioned uh sometime ago,
different communities use different
notations. So,
UK is a typical notation in controls.
Computer science typically use the
notation AK. A stands for action.
XK is the typical notation for the state
in control. Computer science typically
uses SK.
The probability So, the transition
equations are typically written
according to a transition function that
says what the value of the next state is
depending on SK and AK.
So,
this is analogous to what we wrote here.
And there are additional terminologies
from other communities. Like, for
example, from operations research and so
on and so forth. Fortunately, there is a
paper which is called uh
AI OR OR stands for operational research
and control theory, a Rosetta Stone for
stochastic optimization. So, if you get
tripped by the notation uh among
communities, this is a good paper whose
only job is to say that's a symbol we
use in control that seems crazy, right?
But, I mean, these days probably just
going to ask ChatGPT
when uh first I had this reference uh
was a few years ago, ChatGPT was not
there. But, anyway, the point is
different communities use different
terminologies. Don't get tripped.
Now, the good news
is that uh because of the way we
formulated the problem, specifically, we
use the expected value operator
uh to map the random cost into a
deterministic quantity we can optimize
over. And critically, we make the
Markovian assumption.
Intuitively, these two assumptions allow
us to uh chop the problem into pieces.
Chopping means the principle optimality.
Specifically, and the intuition is the
same, we're not going to derive it, but
the proof is not too complicated.
Uh
assume that you have an optimal control
policy pi star.
That means that we have an optimal
policy at time zero, pi star 0 1,
optimal policy at time one, pi star 1,
optimal policy at time n n - 1, pi star
n - 1. So, an optimal policy is indeed a
sequence of n policies, each one mapping
the current state into the current
optimal control.
Consider the tail subproblem. We are at
some state
x of k,
and we only care about what happens
after
time k.
Then, the truncated policy
is uh sorry, we start at the time i.
k is still the running subscript. We
start at time i
with the state x of i,
and we look at uh
the tail problem as from
time i all the way to capital n. Then,
the tail policy, so the policy the
sequence of policies from time i to time
n - 1 is optimal for the tail problem.
Intuition the same as in the
deterministic setting, the proof a
little bit more involved. If you're
interested in the proof,
a good reference is is represented by
the work of Dimitri Bertsekas.
Basically, his optimal control books
are also
referenced in the syllabus.
He provided proof nothing particularly
insightful, so we're going to skip it.
But, of course, as any result, it has to
be proven.
Any questions here?
So, per se the principle of optimality
is not so useful.
It's something interesting to know, but
it doesn't really lend to an actionable
algorithm. The point here is to show
that
to highlight this problem has a specific
structure that allows us to get to
an actionable algorithm, which is really
dynamic programming, but the extended to
the stochastic setting.
And the as we'll see in a second, the
dynamic programming algorithm in a
stochastic setting has exactly the same
form of dynamic programming in a
deterministic setting. So, we start from
the end,
and then we start solving the problem
going backward one stage at a time.
Easier thing to do is just to
show how the algorithm works.
We start from the last stage, capital N,
and we set the
terminal cost J N X of N as the terminal
cost in our cost formulation.
And then we go one step backward
recursively, where at each time stage K
for a given state X of K, we try to find
the
uh optimal control U K
that optimally trades off
the current cost
and the future cost to go.
So, same as the deterministic setting
with the two differences.
The transition function now depends on W
K, but that's obvious, that's how we set
up the problem. Remember Remember that
this is S K + 1, J K + 1 SK + 1 is the
cost of the optimal problem, the tail
problem that starts at time K + 1
at state SK + 1.
And then the key difference with respect
to the deterministic setting is that
this quantity is stochastic, the
current cost
in general depends on a WK.
And the cost to go it's also stochastic
because the transition to the next state
is stochastic.
But so we have to take an expectation
with respect to WK, but importantly in
this computation we only take an
expectation with WK as opposed to the
full
sequence of disturbances from time zero
to time N - 1. So it's a dramatic
simplification.
So you carry out these
computations for every stage K and every
state SK K.
And once you are done going backward all
all the way to time zero
J star at X zero, so the optimal cost of
the problem you're interested in
starting from state X zero is equal to
the end solution of this recursion. And
the optimal policy is constructed by
setting a
a pi star SK as the minimizer of the
Bellman a recursion.
So same as the deterministic setting,
only difference is now we have to deal
with the disturbances.
Correct.
So in stochastic setting in order to
still to keep the structure
you still need that additive structure
on the cost, but then you also need the
Markovian
assumption on the distribution of the
disturbances.
That allows you to devise to derive
dynamic programming
equations to solve the problem.
And for the proof of it,
I reference I refer you to the books of
Dimitri Bertsekas.
Who is a celebrated professor at MIT.
Actually, I was his course assistant
when
he was teaching dynamic programming at
MIT.
Any questions?
Let's do an example just to fix ideas
about what's happening what's happening
here.
So, let's consider the following
problem. So, this is the inventory
control problem. So, you have a
warehouse
and you are storing some stock.
You're purchasing some new stock in
anticipating future demand. And of
course, when once demand for that stock
is realized, then you ship it.
So, we define we now model the problem
as follows. So, we let SK, that's our
state, be the stock
available. For example, number of
refrigerators if our warehouse is
storing refrigerators.
Inventory UK is the number of additional
items that
we get anticipating future demand.
And WK is the demand that gets realized
at time K.
The state at time K plus one, so the
number of units of stock that are
available at the next
um
stage is given by how much stock I have
right now
plus the stock that we purchase. And we
assume that once we purchase it, it gets
immediately delivered.
Minus the demand.
So, if you start with two, we purchase
one, we go to three, then we have a
demand of a two, so we ship two stocks
out. I'm left with one at the next
stage.
If the demand is larger than the stocks
that I do have,
then the number of stock at the next
time stage is equal to zero. And the
demand that is unfulfilled is
unfulfilled.
So, that's why the transition dynamics
are the maximum between zero
and SK plus UK minus WK.
Now, our warehouse is very small,
and so the maximum amount of
stock we can keep in our warehouse is
equal to two, which means that SK plus
UK is less than or equal to two.
Of course, this is a toy problem. The
reason why I'm making this assumption is
since I'm going to do the dynamic
programming recursion by hand, and I
have to do it for each possible value of
the state, I don't want to do it for 25
different values of the state. I
artificially somewhat decrease the
state space.
Now,
what about the disturbance? We need to
specify a probabilistic model for the
disturbance to have a complete problem
formulation. So, in this setting, I'm
assuming that the demand, which is our
disturbance or our stochastic element in
the formulation, does not depend on the
control nor state.
So, it's a simple setting.
Specifically, we assume that at time K,
uh
we have a 10% probability that we have
no demand,
70% probability that we have demand for
one unit,
and uh
20% probability that we have demand for
two units.
Of course, the probability distribution
has to be normalized, so the
probabilities have to sum to one.
And finally, we have to set up the cost.
So, the cost is defined as
zero. So, we assume So, we assume first
of all that we are going to optimize
operations over the horizon of three
steps into the future.
And we assume that the terminal cost is
equal to zero. So, no matter how much
stock I'm left with at the final time,
I don't care. I just dispose of it at no
cost. So, the terminal cost is zero.
And then the stage-wise cost is as
follows. Is it UK, so we assume that we
spend $1 to buy one unit of stock
plus
a quadratic term.
So, this quadratic term has the
following interpretation.
If
after a purchase
UK units of stock and then the demand WK
gets realized, if this quantity is
positive, meaning that I have a
uh
positive amount of stock that have to
keep until the next stage,
that's an undesirable situation because
of course storing stock is expensive.
And I penalize that with the square of
that value.
So, that's the interpretation if this
quantity is positive. If this quantity
is negative, means that
the demand is larger than the amount of
stock that I have available,
I still penalize
this quantity with a square because of
course not fulfilling demand is also an
undesirable situation.
I, for example, damage the trust of my
customers. Of course, this is somewhat
arbitrary and in general how you set up
the cost is arbitrary. You just try to
inject some notion of how happy you are
with a suitable different conditions.
Notice how
all of this depends on the realization
of the different disturbances at time 0,
1, and 2.
So, I transform all of this into the
deterministic quantity by taking
expectation over W0, W1, and W2.
So, now the problem is you are an
operator for this
warehouse, what is your optimal policy?
So, for all possible realization of the
state, say that at time
two, it just so happened that X2 is
equal one, what is the optimal thing
that you should be doing?
You buy one, you buy zero, what do you
do?
Yeah.
It depends on the current amount. So,
basically, how much stock you have right
now in your stock.
So, if at time one, you have a one unit
of stock,
what do you do? Do you purchase one
additional unit of stock, or you do not?
But, the keep in mind
the sequence of events how we have
specified it. So, you get to observe the
state, so you know that at time one you
have a X1 unit of stock,
but you don't know your demand yet at
time one.
Then you have to select how much stock
you want to purchase, and then the
demands get realized.
Well, why do you say that it's expected
demand of one? You expect a demand of
one with 70%.
But, it's also possible
that you get zero with 10%, and it's
also possible that you get two with 20%.
So, it's not so clear-cut.
So, what you know is not what the exact
realization of the disturbance is, it's
a probabilistically what the realization
of the disturbance is might be. So,
that's the knowledge you can
uh you know, leverage.
I mean, we should not realize that when
you invest in stocks, you don't know
exactly what the return on your Tesla
stock is going to be. So, let's say at
the beginning of the day, you don't know
what the return of your the the value of
your Tesla stock is going to be at 12:00
p.m.
You try to anticipate that. So, you have
some probabilistic model, based on that
you want to um
optimize operations.
Yeah.
>> What do we impose the
So, it's a daily constraint that relates
to not wanting two units or more than
two units in the warehouse.
>> Yeah.
Uh but, what does that translate to our
constraint on the action at once?
So,
Well, here basically, I'm modeling that
uh
at the maximum,
you can have two units of stock. So,
your warehouse has some physical limit.
It can't have more than
uh you know, n units.
So, how much you store in the warehouse
is how much you have right now, plus how
much you purchase and gets delivered
immediately.
So, that's the meaning of this
constraint.
But, there's also pedagogical meaning
about why use this constraint. So, this
is a setting whereby UK, your control,
is a constraint by a function of the
state. So, this is a case whereby the
explicit dependency of the set capital U
on SK arises.
>> No, what
you have is that using your stock SK
plus UK minus WK only in SK.
>> Well, the reason is that So, this is
your warehouse.
And you have this amount of stock.
And you have only this space here.
Then you should you
purchase with you this space here.
And then the demand is realized
afterwards. So, it's not like
immediately realized. So, basically,
there is a moment in time where you
can't really fit more stock in there.
Yeah.
So, think about W as something that
happens after
non-infinitesimal amount of time after
you purchase your stock.
Again, some of these assumptions can be
changed, right? Yeah.
I want to give you like a realistic
example, but also something that is
manageable to and also highlight some of
the features of the problem formulation.
So, the question is how do you solve
this problem?
So, the way you solve it is uh
by being disciplined
and running
dynamic programming recursion. So,
specifically
you set the terminal cost J3 X3
as a G3 X3.
And for this problem formulation, we
said that this terminal cost is equal to
zero.
So, this is by how we define the
problem.
So.
And then you start going one step
um
backward in time. So, now we have a J2
X2
is equal to
the
uh minimum
over U2 has to be greater than zero and
has to be less than or equal to X2 minus
two. So, these are the control
constraints they were discussing.
Expectation
over uh W2
of a G of X2
U2
W2
plus G3
X3.
Okay?
Now, from the
recursion, we know that this is equal to
zero.
So, we write down
the this explicitly
uh what we get.
What we get is J2 X2
equal minimum
of U2 between zero. I cannot buy
negative amount of stocks.
And X2 minus two because of the capacity
constraints warehouse expectation with
respect to W2
of
Now, I'm going to write down the
stage-wise cost explicitly.
So, this is going to be equal to
It's going to be equal to
U2
right?
Plus
X2 plus plus U2 minus W2
squared.
There is no cost to go because already
set that the cost to go to stage three
is equal to zero because of the previous
recursion. Well,
um I use the boundary condition.
Any questions here?
Yeah.
Two minus X2. Yeah, 100%.
Sorry about that.
That's absolutely correct because the
constraint is U2 plus X2
less than equal to
Yeah. Thank you for noticing that.
All right. So, now that you have read
you have written down the Bellman
equation for
state X of two at stage two,
now you have to solve it for all
possible values of the states.
What are the possible values of the
states?
Zero,
one, and two, because you can't have
more than two stocks.
So, which one Okay, so let's do it for
J20.
So, of course, in general, a computer
would do it.
But, it's useful for for you to carry
out the some of these Bellman recursions
by hand.
It's a bit annoying. It There is no
cleverness or smartness, nothing.
But, it's helpful in order to better
appreciate that what's happening here.
Practically, your final exam, I would
ask you to carry out a Bellman equation
by hand. So,
uh I like to say it's like a vaccine.
It's a bit annoying, but you do it once,
and then you're fine for life. So, do
it.
Anyway, so let's do it for one. Then you
maybe you can do it for J21 or J22
uh by yourself. So, for J20,
so now we have minimum
over U2 greater than or equal to zero.
Now, we are solving the tail problem
where X2 is equal to zero, which means
that the constraint is now U2 less than
or equal to two, because we are plugging
zero into X2. So, uh U2 between zero and
uh two
of expectations with respect to W2
of this quantity here.
>> [snorts]
>> Well, so what's the expectation of this
quantity? Well,
with a 10% probability,
with 10% probability, W W2 is equal to
zero.
So, with 10% probability
So, this is a random variable. Its
realization is uh
for a given selection of U2 is U2 plus
X2 is zero
plus U2
minus zero squared.
I mean, I'm a a bit pedantic here, but
So, that's the case where W2 is equal
zero.
Plus
then I had the case where W2 is equal to
one, which is 70%.
So, plus a 0.7
I mean, as an aside
the expectation of a random variable X
is equal to the summation of
for I equal one to N
of what?
So, if you have a random variables that
can take a N values like size, each one
with probability PIs
Yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> So, that's what I'm doing here. So, it's
0.7
of U2
plus the state is still zero
plus U2 minus one squared.
And then I have a plus
should be 20%
So, zero
um
plus a 0.2
of U2
plus zero
plus U2 minus two squared.
And now I have to find the u2 that
minimizes this expression.
So, does this make sense? Essentially,
you have a unrolled the expectations
with respect to the three possible
realizations of uh
the
um
disturbances w2, each one weighted with
its respective likelihood of happening.
Yeah.
>> And if we started with initial top value
of one,
then all of the first terms in those
parentheses should be one, right?
>> One?
One? One? Yes.
Uh
And here, you should also change the
constraint set because now u2 can only
be between between 0 and 1.
You got 2 - 1. So, you'll have a change
here, too.
The probability distribution wouldn't
change because we're assuming that the
probability distribution that it is not
conditional on the exact value of the
state. So, these numbers will be the
same.
Okay, so this becomes a J20
in minimum over u2 between the two
and zero of
0.1 u2 0.7 u2 0.2 u2. Of course,
probability sums to one, so this is
equal to u2.
Plus
u2 squared
uh times 0.1
plus a 0.7
uh u2 - 1
squared plus 0.2
u2
- 2
squared
which is uh
exactly what you have here.
So, you plug u2 = 0, you get a value.
You plug you do equal one, you get a
value. You plug you do equal two, you
get a value. You pick the you do that
gives you the lowest value.
Just so happens that the optimal choice
is uh
one.
So, that means that if you happen at
stage number two to be in state X2 equal
zero, then the optimal thing to do for
you is to
purchase one. And cannot make sense.
That's also what your colleague was
hinting at.
That since we have such a high
probability that we have a demand of
one,
you want to buy an additional stock so
that you can fulfill it. So,
it's not too surprising.
>> [snorts]
>> Anyway,
so it turns out that if you do
the this computation now for
the state equal to one,
the state equal to two, and then you go
back to J1 and J0,
the
the optimal value
for each possible initial condition is
as follows.
So, we'd encourage you to do some of
these computations, maybe not all but at
least some of them. The result for each
recursion, for each possible state, each
possible state
uh stage is in the spreadsheet that
linked here. So, just click on the link
and you'll get the spreadsheet with all
the values so that you can cross-check
what that what you're doing is correct.
Yeah, keep in mind this is a cost. So,
in general, the lower the better. So,
yes, state one will be the best to start
with. Which again cannot make sense.
It's in between uh
uh
is in between, so you're not at risk of
a missing demand, but at the same time
you don't have to buy
uh a lot of new stock. So, roughly
speaking, it's not too surprising that
something in the middle for this
specific problem is a a place to be. So,
short answer is yes.
>> So, does this give us like the optimal
policy to take from any state at any
point? Or if we like if we use like 0.1
and 0.2
and then like we have something
like W
or command,
will we have to will we have to
re-evaluate
>> No.
>> You will be given the optimal policy
because of the principle of optimality.
So, as you go back, all the decisions
are optimal at each step of the time.
So, no, the sequence of policies if it's
0.1 or 0.2
always gives you the best option of
things to do.
>> at all stages, all states. You don't
have to re-optimize anything.
So, that's pretty powerful.
Yeah.
So, that's a little bit of a problem
with dynamic programming. As you've seen
the homework, it does provide
significant computational savings
whereas we do brute force optimization,
but still
it's pretty time-consuming, particularly
because you have a dependency on the
number of states. So, in this case the
state is one-dimensional.
X can only adjust one number.
But if now X is
a pair,
then you have to
your scaling goes quadratically and
cubically and basically exponentially
with the number of dimensions in terms
of how many computations you have to
carry out.
In this case specifically, it's not.
It's basically three for the states and
then you have to go,
you know, you have three stages.
So, three by three. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, if you have a continuous state
space, you cannot run this algorithm
because you cannot enumerate all
possible states.
So, you can do a few things. So, one
could be
uh discretizing your states,
of course,
uh or map your state of this
presentation something lower dimensional
and then discretize it there. But yeah,
at some point you have to get to
something you can do
uh numerical optimization on.
Let's look at another example. So,
our preferred problem, which is LQR. So,
we're going to look at the LQR with a
yet another twist.
So, same setting as before, we have a
quadratic cost.
Only difference is that now our dynamics
are affected by
a disturbance W, which is a stochastic
quantity, that is distributed as a
Gaussian variable with a zero mean
and uh covariance matrix sigma.
So, LQR problem as before, only
difference is that the dynamics are now
stochastic.
So, the question is, can we use dynamic
programming to solve this problem? The
answer is yes, in a way it is extremely
similar
to what we did uh a couple of lectures
ago.
Specifically,
the way it works is that
inspired by what we know from um
the solution to LQR in a deterministic
setting,
let's assume
um
that the cost JX JK XK is equal to some
quadratics,
quadratic,
plus possibly
some constants. Let's call it CK.
Remember that for LQR,
the
um
There is a typo here. This should be PK
+ 1.
Uh I'll fix that. Um
so remember that in a standard LQR, the
cost to go is quadratic. It's a
quadratic form on the state.
Okay.
So,
Oh, come on. I have two another typo
here. So, this should be SK.
I don't know what I was thinking. So,
this should be JK or SK,
and this should be SK + 1 PK + 1 SK + 1.
So, I'll fix these two typos.
So, how do we solve this problem? We
write down the Bellman equation. So, JK
SK, again, K + 1 is a typo here, is
equal to minimum of UK expectation of WK
stage-wise cost plus cost to go.
So,
assuming the cost to go is a quadratic,
so is SK + 1 PK + 1 SK + 1 plus a
constant, I'm ignoring it here.
Now, let's unroll this multiplication.
Here, I'm quite fast because this is
essentially something we already
covered. So, we have a AX U
PK AX + BU. So, that's exactly the
quadratic term we had in standard LQR.
Plus, I have the quadratic term in WK,
which is here, plus I have the cross
terms between AX and BU and W,
which is here, and I have a two of them.
So, this is just by unrolling this
multiplication.
So, now I'm taking the expectation of
this quantity. So,
this is a constant,
so its expectation is exactly XQX. This
is a constant, so the expectation is
the same quantity. This is also
constant, that's not dependent on WK.
The only two things that depend on WK is
this term and this term.
This term is linear in WK,
and we're assuming that WK is zero mean.
So, the expectation of all of this stuff
is zero because the expectation of W is
zero.
So, if you have a random variable, say
that you have a A
times X. You know that expectation of X
is equal to zero.
What is the expectation of the
AX for A being a real number?
Zero. A times expectation of X. But,
expectation of X is zero, so that's
equal to zero.
So, this is exactly what's happening
here.
Whoop.
What is it? Here. Okay.
The term that is not obvious is what is
the expectation of W PK + 1 W.
So, it turns out, we're not going to
prove it, basically relies on some basic
facts related to um linear algebra, is
that the expectation of W PK W where W
is a Gaussian variable with covariance
sigma
is equal
to the trace of PK + 1 times the
covariance of W. Remember that the trace
is equal to the sum of the elements of
the diagonal of a matrix.
This is not obvious.
I'm just giving you giving this to you
as uh
as a fact. So, basically, I'm telling
you that expectation of
W transpose
PK + 1
WK
is equal to the trace, which is the sum
of the elements of the diagonal of a
matrix, of PK + 1
times the covariance sigma
of the variables WK. That we assume we
know because we assume that we know that
this variance is at zero mean and we're
given co-covariance sigma.
The proof requires a two three steps.
Um, not particularly insightful, so
we're skipping it here.
The point I want to make here is that
look at what we found, that the right
hand side of the Bellman equation is
exactly the one that we had in LQR
plus a constant term.
So, these are quantities that we already
know. PK + 1 from the computation that
we already carried out at time K + 1,
and sigma is part of our modeling
knowledge.
Which means that when we
try to find the optimal control U,
what would be the solution?
Is exactly equal to deterministic LQR
plus a constant. So, when I I try to
find the optimal control, I take the
derivative
with respect to U, the constant goes
away because it doesn't depend on U. So,
the solution that I will find is exactly
the solution that we found for LQR,
linear feedback on the state. I plug
that back into the cost,
I get
a quadratic with respect to the state
plus a constant.
So, we started from a cost to go at time
K + 1 that was a quadratic plus a
constant. I get again a quadratic plus a
constant. So, all of this to say,
without
spending too much time here, is that uh
for stochastic LQR, the control control
policy is the same, the cost is almost
the same. The only difference is that
the cost the cost is increased by some
constant related to the magnitude of the
noise.
Which kind of makes sense.
We have to pay something because now we
are operating in a
um
uncertain setting.
All right. This was just one other
example to to showcase the use of uh
stochastic dynamic programming for the
LQR problem.
Yeah.
>> What if you also include the case where
the variance of the stochastic uh term
was dependent
on the control?
>> Yeah.
>> Like the probability is like a function
>> Yeah. Of course, because now once you
start
taking the derivative with respect to U,
this term wouldn't go to zero anymore.
So, actually the formulation Yeah,
absolutely.
What we exploit here
is that sigma
is just a given quantity that does not
depend neither on state nor on control.
Cool. All right. So,
one additional item Maybe we're going to
conclude this item
on Wednesday.
And this will become important when we
move into the second part of this class,
namely reinforcement learning, imitation
learning, learning.
So, so far we have introduced the
stochastic optimal control problems or
optimal control problems in a finite
horizon setting. So, basically we assume
that we are optimizing operations over
15 steps, 20 steps, 35 steps.
Uh
but as you will see,
for a number of reasons, the RL problem
or imitation learning problem,
particularly RL problem, reinforcement
learning problem, is formulated within
an infinite horizon setting.
So, we assume that now we're trying to
optimize operations over infinite number
of
stages. So, the number of stages is
infinite.
Now, of course, the function [snorts] of
an infinite number of stages is never
fulfilled in practice, of course. Our
lifetime is limited. The life of the
universe is arguably
um
um limited, but is a good approximation
for those problem involving a finite,
but very a very large number of, uh,
stages.
And, as we will see, it simplifies the
problem considerably. So, it's again a
sort of a compromise between being
something that is quite reasonable in
many settings,
and also simplifying the problem even
further.
Specifically, an infinite horizon Markov
decision process is a problem where by,
as usual, we have a state X, or in a
computer science notation, S.
We have an action U,
and we have a transition function that
tells us what the next state XT will be,
given the current value of the state XT
- 1 and current value of the control UT
- 1.
Now, since we're getting closer to the
RL formulation, typically in
reinforcement learning, people don't
talk about cost, they talk about
rewards.
So, instead of minimizing a cost, we
maximize a reward.
And that is just a minor modification.
Each problem can be mapped into the
other one,
uh, by just swapping minimization with
maximization and adding a a sign minus,
uh, in in front of the quantity you're
interested in.
We introduce the notion of discount
factor gamma. I will talk about it, uh,
shortly.
And so, an infinite horizon problem is
defined by these, uh,
uh, five quantities here.
We knew four of them. There is a fifth
one that I'm introducing, gamma. I'm
going to explain it in a second.
The point I want to make here
is that now,
everything in this formulation is, uh,
stationary.
What that means is that the transition
probability from,
uh,
the state at time T - 1 and control at
time T - 1 into the state at time T does
not depend on the specific stage T - 1.
Remember that, uh, before
the transition model was allowed to
depend explicitly on time. So, even if
you are the same state, same control,
and you have the same relation to
disturbance today and tomorrow, in
general, the transition to the next
state might be different.
In a infinite horizon MDP, we're making
assumption that the problem formulation
is stationary.
Why do we make a stationary assumption?
One again because often times is a
decent one for processes whose dynamics
don't change dramatically from stage to
stage, but two, in a infinite horizon
MDP, as you can imagine, we are trying
to use some limit concept. And so, doing
limits when underlying problem
formulation changes, it will be very,
very hard.
So.
Uh again, compromise between being
reasonable and uh making computation
feasible.
Now,
our goal is to find a policy
that optimizes the expected cost-to-go.
But now we are Sorry, reward-to-go.
So, now we're talking about rewards and
not costs.
And now we have this additional term
gamma that multiplies the reward, gamma
to the power of t. So, gamma is a number
between 0 and 1 and is referred to as a
discount factor.
So, why do we multiply our reward by
this constant to the power of t? We
didn't have that in the finite horizon
formulation.
Any hypothesis about why people do that?
Exactly. So, that's the intellectual
explanation that in general, when you
try to optimize
operations,
you of course place a lot of emphasis on
the consequences of your decisions in
the next few time steps. You don't care
too much about what the consequences
might be
1 month from now or 1 year from now,
which kind of makes sense.
But as usual, there is also the
pragmatic uh
uh explanation. What is the pragmatic
explanation?
Exactly. So, since now we are in an
infinite horizon setting, so this is sum
from zero to plus infinity, and so in
general, for any reasonable reward, this
will be equal to plus infinity. So, if
all policies have a cost equal to plus
infinity, which one is optimal?
They're all plus infinity. They're all
phenomenal, right? So, that's why you uh
and you put like an an exponential
waiting because typically exponentials
kill a lot of uh functions.
Is it a common theme where people
pre-append the quantities of an
exponential to ensure convergence?
Anyway.
Just wanted to highlight why people use
this counting factor. Again, it makes
sense, but also practically. Is there a
question?
Do you You have a question?
>> Oh, no. I think we're good.
>> No. Okay, great.
So, infinite horizon DP, problem is
stationary, we are now focusing on
rewards, we have this addition of a
discount factor in our modeling.
Now,
since the problem is stationary and we
are in an infinite horizon,
the policies the optimal policy doesn't
depend anymore on the stage you are at.
So, you don't have a P0, P1, P2 anymore.
You just have pi.
So, we're just optimizing over pi.
Uh a mapping between state at any stage
in time into a control action.
Remember that before we were optimizing
over P0, P1, P2. Here, we just optimize
over a single pi.
Because a stationary policy, that is a
policy that does not does not depend
explicitly on time, is indeed optimal.
Yeah.
>> Are you saying that the optimal policy
has to be stationary?
>> We focus only on stationary policies.
Yes, that's what we're saying here.
Correct.
Okay. So, then the question is how do we
solve
How do we solve such a such problem?
Guesses?
Well, we try to reuse whatever we
learned from a finite horizon optimal
control,
which is the notion of a Bellman
uh equation.
So,
trying to
exploit that intuition,
remember that when we were in a finite
horizon setting, we said that the
optimal cost or optimal rewards
satisfy a recursive equation.
So, it's natural to wonder if an
infinite horizon setting
if you let the number of stages to go to
infinity, basically you take a limit on
both sides,
that stuff will converge to something.
So, basically remember that you have a
uh J of K X K is equal to
maximum over
U K of uh
expectation over W K of uh
um
Actually, let me do it with a cost since
we were talking about cost with a J
formulation.
Oop, there is a
G K X K U K
W K plus
J K plus one S K plus one.
So,
assuming our problem is stationary,
does this stuff converge to
something?
And if this stuff converge to something
and I take the limit here and here,
do I get a sort of a stationary Bellman
equation?
The answer is yes. So, actually, the
cost function
in the limited horizon goes to infinity,
does converge to a steady state
quantity.
And that steady state quantity satisfies
a
not a recursive equation such as there,
but fixed point equation, which is
represented here. So, this is the
extension of the Bellman equation to an
infinite horizon setting.
Whereby
V,
which is the same as a J, but when
people talk about rewards, they like to
call refer to it as V. V stands for
value.
So, reward values, cost Js. I don't know
what J stands for, actually.
Anyway.
So, V star X is equal to maximum over U
of the immediate reward plus the
expectation of the reward to go.
So,
in infinite horizon problem, one can
prove that the optimal value function,
so the
value of the problem assuming that you
start at X and you follow an optimal
policy, satisfies a fixed point equation
whereby V star X is equal to max over U
of R plus expected cost to go.
Discounted by gamma, one step discount
factor.
So, we take this as a fact.
There is a bit of a proof that uses some
uh uh limit considerations. But again,
from intuition standpoint, I'm trying to
give you some justification. The
justification is that this looks very
similar to the Bellman equation,
but in an infinite horizon setting, the
recursive equation becomes just an
equation.
>> Now,
when you're solving these, how do you
inform the algorithm to not keep
searching? Because obviously, like with
the discount factor, you probably see
the point like clearly some earlier
stopping point would be more optimal
than the later one. But how do you
distinguish like when it's not even
worth to keep searching? Because maybe
there is like some
minimal point.
>> Yeah.
>> Like steps away.
>> Yeah. So, keep in mind that here,
I'm not giving you an actual model
algorithm yet. I'm just uh highlighting
a key property of infinite horizon MDPs
whereby the optimal value functions
satisfy an equation.
How we translate this information into a
search algorithm,
that's something we'll see at the
beginning of the next lecture.
And basically, we can do it a couple of
ways.
Uh
value iteration algorithms and policy
iteration algorithms. For now, this is
just a derived property of our problem
formulation.
Just so happens
that if you're not interested in the
optimal value function, but you're
actually interested in the following
question, if I give you any policy pi,
what is the cumulative reward
that that policy is going to collect?
Turns out
that the value for that policy
satisfies a very similar fixed point
equation.
But now we don't have a maximization of
a U anymore because we're fixing the
policy.
And then the computation of the U's are
simply with respect to the policy pi
that is given.
Note that this is given to you. This is
given to you.
So, assuming that X
has a finite number of realizations,
this is actually a linear system of
equations with respect to the value
function B.
So,
you could potentially solve
this equation by solving a linear system
of equations.
>> Can you quickly clarify why previously
for dynamic programming the cost
function depended on the disturbance,
but here
>> Yes, here it depends still on the
disturbance.
But the stochastic dependency is more
cryptically
captured by this transition function.
That is uh
T
is the probability of going into a new
state X prime given X and U.
So, it's what I was saying before, and
here I made a little bit of a change of
notation as I mentioned, from the
control theory notation to the computer
science notation.
So, you can write
X K + 1
= f of X K
U K W K
and then say that W K follows some
probability P K of
conditional X K U K
or equivalently, you can say that so
what they give you is a P
and F in order to compute the next X or
I can just give you this object T
XK + 1
given XKUK.
So this is directly the probability
distribution of the next state
given X and U. The two are actually
identical. They can be mapped to each
other. The difference then notationally
the dependence on disturbance here is
explicit. Here is a little bit more
cryptic.
But
the point being the dynamics are still
stochastic and the stochasticity is
captured by the probability distribution
of the next state given X and U. Note
that this model is clearly Markovian in
the sense that the dependence on the
past is all only with respect to the
current value of the state X and the
current action U.
All right. One more thing and then we'll
wrap it up. I'll talk about the
algorithms to solve for the infinite
horizon Bellman equation the next time.
You You won't be too long. It'll be only
15-20 minutes.
There's an alternative way of writing
the
infinite horizon Bellman equation.
It seems very benign but actually it's
been quite revolutionary
especially
to derive learning based algorithms.
Specifically, let's define something
that is referred to as a Q function.
The Q function is simply the right hand
side of the infinite horizon Bellman
equation. And it has the following
interpretation.
>> [snorts]
>> It is the
cumulative reward that you collect
assuming that uh
you start at X
you play control U
and then you act optimally after that
according to the policy pi star.
So, if you are state X and you use
control U and then you are optimally
rewarded
from the next state stage onward, your
community cost is RXU plus
the optimal reward to go from the
perspective of the next state. But, of
course, the next state is stochastic, so
you have to average the different
realizations of the next state.
So, you say, "Who cares?"
I'll tell you in 1 second why you care.
But, first, I want to show that the
assuming that you care about the Q star
Q functions,
the Q functions satisfy a fundamental
equation that is uh
essentially the same as the Bellman
equation, but for Q functions,
specifically.
And this seems to be like uh
um
a little bit circuitous.
So, we said that the Q star
is by definition RXU
plus gamma
sum over next state X prime of the
realization of the next states
times V star X prime.
So, that's the definition of uh
Q.
But, then we also have the
condition that V star X, again,
following our definition, is equal to
max
over U of Q star XU.
So, you plug this into here and now you
have a fixed point equation for the Q
functions.
Okay, so that's
that's fine.
But then the question for me should be
why do we care about the Q functions?
In principle, you don't care about them.
But let's assume and of course we will
revisit this setting
at a great extent.
Let's assume that now
some part of the model are not known.
So
you don't know this probability
distribution T.
And you have some algorithm, learning
algorithm, reinforcement learning
algorithm or imitation learning. Let's
say reinforcement learning algorithm
that allows you to learn approximately
the Q functions.
We'll see which algorithms we can use.
So some part of the MDP problem is not
known anymore.
Like the transition kernel is not known.
But we're learning an approximation for
Q. And now I'm asking you to compute the
optimal action given that you are at
state X.
So what do you do? Well, if an oracle
gives you the Q star XU
then your optimal action is simply
the one that maximizes the Q.
Okay. So basically if an oracle gives
you the optimal Q function, then
computing an optimal action is trivial.
You just solve the optimal Well, trivial
I mean, it could be a high-dimensional
problem, but at least you have a way to
do so.
Say that actually oracle gives you the V
star function,
the optimal value function.
How do you compute the optimal action?
Well, now
the optimal action is going to be max
of you
of r x u
plus gamma sum of t x prime
x u with star x prime.
And so, even if I give you the optimal
value function
to compute the optimal action
you need
to know
the transition kernel.
But, if you're in the learning setting
where we assume that we don't have
access to the transition kernel, that
becomes a problem. That's why this
somewhat very benign reformulation of
the problem has been extremely
influential in order to derive learning
algorithms because that allows you to
much more directly find actional
algorithm for optimal action estimation.
Just to want to the first time I saw Q
function said, "Okay, this is completely
useless. I'm just
writing one thing in terms of another
quantity." Why is that? People typically
don't really discuss that.
But, that's a big difference that
if you then reframe the problem through
the notion of Q function, then back
tracking and optimal control action
becomes much more natural in the setting
where some elements of the MDP problem
are not known is not known, for example,
the transition probabilities.
Make sense?
So, [snorts] what we're going to
see next time is a couple of algorithms
to
uh
given a policy there is also an
analogy equation to compute a Q function
for the specific policy. So, Q pi x u is
the value of the problem assuming that
you are at state x, you use control u,
and then you use the policy pi
uh for all stages afterwards. So, what
we're going to see next time is a couple
of algorithm to solve the infinite
horizon MDP problem, value iteration
algorithm and policy iteration
algorithms.
And then, we're going to move into the
topic of continuous time closed-loop
optimal control. We'll get back to
infinite-horizon MDPs and their
extension to the set of learning-based
control in a couple of weeks.